improvements to accessibility in games
has become more of a focus over the
previous console generation
and thankfully great strides have been
made in opening up our favorite hobby
to many more people who require
additional considerations
in order to enjoy their experiences many
studios have dedicated
accessibility consultants in-house and
some games feature
options to tailor the experience to
accommodate for a raft of requirements
from high contrast options for the
vision impaired to offering alternative
control schemes for those with physical
disabilities
i spoke to steve saylor content creator
and video game accessibility consultant
and media editor at can i play that
about what accessibility means
and the progress the industry has made
in improving it generally it's usually
described
as a settings or options that make a
game
playable for those with disabilities
whether
you're blind deaf or hard of hearing or
have voter disabilities
there are settings that kind of will
enable those players to be able to
remove some of the barriers that they
may have with the abilities that they
have
so that they can be able to play the
same game
as their friends are playing with the
same challenge that they have
without a disability semi-auto rifle
semi-auto rifle ammo
nine loaded nine reserve
we really didn't see anything for
accessibility uh in any of
any game the very first assassin's creed
game didn't even have
subtitles whereas now when you look at
the
latest version valhalla it has far more
accessibility options
than uh than the first game did and so
it took a long time to be able to get to
this point but it really kind of ramped
up within the past few years where
advocates like myself and consultants
like myself have been able to talk to
developers
and encourage them to add these options
and talk to disabled players because
they want to be able to play those games
and and not only is that sort of like a
good
thing to do but it also can translate
into sales as well
now when we're going into uh next gen
we're seeing a lot more awareness of
accessibility and whether that's in part
because the last of us part two this
year
or just the momentum in general our
conversations are
becoming more prominent and a majority
of people know about accessibility
and a lot of those people are developers
and they want to be able to try to make
their games
available and for everyone in recent
years game developers and designers have
been more proactive about improving
accessibility
and reaching out to advocates like steve
who worked on the last of us part 2
has been key to that however
fundamentally each console has its own
accessibility challenges that many don't
think about and require more involvement
from platform holders and the industry
at large
to address in a twitter thread earlier
this year
steve called the 100 difference in price
between the disc and digital editions of
the ps5
are disability tax citing the
playstation store's inflexible refund
policy
is an issue for many gamers with
accessibility requirements
obviously there are two different
versions of playstation 5 you have the
digital and the disk version
generally a lot of disabled players
usually prefer to
purchase the physical copy of a game
mainly because a lot of the refund
policies
from if you purchase the game digitally
are not at a place yet
where they can be able to at least get
their money back because often times
whenever we have to be able to put down
like 60 dollars plus that's a lot of
money
for for some people to spend on a game
and if a disabled player
pays that amount for a game they take it
home and
they play it and they realize an hour in
i can't play this that's a lot of money
to be able to kind of uh
sort of in a way be wasted and if you
buy it digitally
oftentimes the refund policy is well
you already downloaded it so we can't
give you a refund
whereas if we buy it physically at least
we could be able to
take it back to the store and even
though we can't get a full refund
we more likely can be able to trade it
in to be able to at least get some of
our money back and when it comes to
sort of the disability tax i had
mentioned with the ps5
it basically costs uh in some cases a
hundred dollars more
to be able to have access to that also
as well the ability to be able to use
game pass as a selling point for the new
consoles is
a huge accessibility advantage because
like i mentioned regards to
sort of the disability tax what's great
about game pass
is that you can be able to get games day
one of release from xbox first party
studios
and when you have the be able to get
those games by paying a certain amount
per month you could be able to download
those games day one
and you can play it try it out if it's
if it doesn't work for you and you're
not able to play it
you can easily delete it download a new
one and
you're not wasting a huge amount of
money for it as consoles move towards an
all digital future
and with accessibility features rarely
included in a game's marketing prior to
launch
subscription services such as xbox game
pass become
all the more important in ensuring that
gamers with individual requirements
don't end up unfairly out of pocket
playstation does offer playstation now
but its library is by comparison
skewed much more towards older games and
unlike game pass
does not generally include new first
party titles upon release
there's also the playstation plus
collection but once again this consists
of last gen games
until accessibility features are common
as part of a game's marketing
or sony changes their refund policy to
account for accessibility
it may continue to be gamers with those
requirements who foot the bill
there are also considerations to be made
when it comes to the hardware itself
it's a mundane point but a larger
heavier console or one that requires you
to attach a stand with a small screw
means that many people with physical
disabilities may find themselves unable
to unbox and set up their new console
without the assistance of someone else
which given the world is currently in
the midst of a pandemic
is far from ideal a headline feature for
the ps5 is the brand new dualsense
controller which features haptic
feedback and adaptive triggers
but these settings can be disabled on a
system level as well as individually in
titles such as mars morales
which offers accessibility vibration
frustratingly these additions mean that
the dualshock 4 and other ps4 compatible
controllers
are not supported for ps5 games which
will be a concern to those who have a
personalized setup
adapted to old hardware by contrast
microsoft has ensured that any
compatible xbox one generation
controller works without issue on the
series x and s
as with the xbox one you can remap
buttons on a system level
and the xbox adaptive controller is
supported along with the adaptive gaming
kit
though microsoft deserves ploridix for
being the only major company with an
official adaptive controller and the
only one selling additional third-party
solutions on its site
it should be noted that the controller
and kit could set you back over 200
dollars
not including the external joysticks
that are required for the xbox uh series
x and s
what microsoft did was they actually
kind of took a lot of what they had
already developed internally and refined
it
for next generation so if you're coming
from an
xbox one and you're using the
accessibility settings uh
in the ease of access menu in the xbox
it's the exact same
ease of access menu on the series x and
s
and so you're going to get the same
experience that's on the xbox side on
the playstation side actually what they
did was
kind of interesting pretty much the same
settings that is on
playstation 4 is on the playstation 5.
they have also
kind of enhanced a lot for blind players
before
there was a text-to-speech option in the
playstation 4
that unfortunately was only available in
english only but now with the
playstation
5 they've enabled screen reader to be
available
in multiple languages across the world
so
you can be able to turn on the console
for day one when you get it and it will
guide you through the setup process and
you can be able to keep that on
throughout the rest of your setup fast
too fast three
and it's an amazing way to be able to
kind of navigate the system and it works
flawlessly
across the entire operating system of
the playstation
voice type voice volume and then when it
comes to sort of like the dual sense
controller that i have here
uh with the haptic feedback it basically
adds a lot more immersion for blind
players as well
where the precise and subtle details of
the vibrations in the controller
actually help blind players to be able
to feel the environment that they're
in and know when they're walking or when
they're
being attacked when things are kind of
moving from side to side
and that along with sort of like the 3d
audio that's built into it is
a really amazing feature and actually
playstation has a
neat little feature in it called game
presets where any game you play will
automatically turn on
whatever difficulty setting you want to
be able to set whether to turn on
subtitles
or to invert controls and enable
settings that you normally would have to
turn on whenever you start up a game for
the first time i'm really excited to be
able to see
what else they can that sony and
microsoft can be able to do
moving forward now that accessibility in
a way is kind of built in
from from the ground up it's clear the
industry has come a long way
in the past 10 years in recognizing the
challenges that some people face
just to be able to play games at all but
hopefully this is the beginning of a
progression towards a future
where all games are open to everybody no
matter their individual requirements
as far as for xbox what i love to be
able to see from them and they actually
are
are doing that is internally in their
studios they are pushing for
accessibility um pretty much on every
single project that
every studio is working on in their xbox
game studio
and they have an internal accessibility
team called gaming for everyone i really
love to be able to
see where that goes and and i'm loving
what what uh what xbox
their initiatives have kind of done what
i would like to be able to see over the
next
five to ten years for accessibility in
games is
i'm i'm a content creator so creating
reviewing games is kind of
what i get to do i would love it for the
industry to get to a point where
five years down the road i can be sort
of nitpicking
certain accessibility options instead of
just saying
why doesn't this game have some that's
what i would love to be able to get
get to that point um where every game
has a standard
of accessibility and we can be able to
open this genre or this art form up to
more people i love what kind of
microsoft uh kind of put out a couple
years ago when they released the
adaptive controller
and they used this phrase internally is
when everybody plays we all win
and that's something that we in the
community adopted
and really tried to build a showcase
that games are for everyone
and games should be for everyone and
that's something
and accessibility is is a huge part of
that last year we spoke to rod ferguson
of the coalition who went into detail
about microsoft's push for accessibility
features
among its first party titles you can
check out that episode of audio logs
in the link below for more information
on accessibility within gaming i'd
recommend checking out can i play that
which offers in-depth accessibility
focused reviews of gaming hardware and
software and there are a number of
charitable organizations like special
effect
and the ablegamers charity dedicated to
enabling people with disabilities
to enjoy games for more on the past
present
and future of gaming keep it locked to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gamespot
[Music]
you